alors delgal c'est paper monsters ces
monstres de papier dont vous parlez en
fait vous dites que c'est des monstres
que vous vous étiez créer vous même
c'est la drogue c'est l'alcool et vous
aussi comme pierre botton vous êtes
guéri
voilà moque je ne sais pas si je suis
guéri je crois pas qu'on puisse vraiment
guéri il ya vraiment de guérison il n'ya
pas de guérison mais disons que j'ai
beaucoup changé de choses dans ma vie
mais qui ne fonctionne et c'est de cette
façon je crois qu'on peut dire que
disons que je peux m'identifier un petit
peu monsieur bouton disons que moi j'ai
s'impliquer beaucoup de sous-traitants
les monstres oui je parle surtout de
déclin des angoisses et de fait tout
voir et de pouvoir faire face à ses
angoisses ils faire des choses qu'on
n'aurait pas fait parce qu'on a créé
justement des mots se pose même nom se
cache derrière ces bombes a tendance à
se cacher derrière ça et puis un jour il
faut quand même dépasser cela alors
votre ville est différente maintenant
vous lever tôt
vous accompagnez votre fils à l'école
vous faites de la gymnastique vous fait
du jogging deux fils naoufel pierre
bayle d'entre vous faites des exercices
vocaux enfin tout ce à quoi est-ce que
vous savez c'est bien c'est bien parce
qu'en plus je vais vous dire vous avez
quand même je pense que vous avez pris
je sais pas quelle quantité vous avez
pris de drogue et d'alcool dans tous les
cas c'est vachement bien êtes bien
conservés drogués
bon c'est vrai c'est vrai il emmène bien
c'est arrivé je suis dit voilà ça c'est
le seul problème de ces groupes dans les
années 80 c'est qu'ils ont pas vécu
comme les z deep purple un la grosse
défoncer les gros seins gris et
finalement je m'aperçois qu'il a vécu la
même chose mais il s'en tire super bien
et quadragénaires c'est un bel âge pour
un non sens bosses des sauts des noms
qui connaît les quadragénaires c'est un
vieux sage et des quadragénaires ue pour
lui et moi 40e à une époque quand même
vous vous aviez un ange gardien avec
vous qui s'appelait aident et qui était
un ancien morales ancien drogué qui vous
suivait partout et c est ce que vous
l'avez toujours non j'ai parlé récemment
avec nos habitats détruits dans le chic
en fait avec moi une fois mais depuis
c'est quelqu'un de bien surtout quand je
suis retourné précisément c'est pas mal
des trappes d'avoir un copain avec soin
hélène ségara je connais pas
man 2
hélène ségara when she was you mia mais
orlando lui a demandé de chanter autre
chose que du détachement mais en plus il
avait un vrai look
tu vois il s'appelle pas comme ça par
hasard ils veulent des années 80 et de
tout ce qu'ils ont emporté tout cas on
va y voit la mort dans ces chiens qu'est
ce que tu fais tu fais un chat mais j'ai
dit c'est parce que yahia ma fille m'a
demandé de dessiner un g10 et d'achat
qui ce qui se joue avec une seringue
dans laquelle il ya des souris un peu
dur à elle ça veut dire à passer dans
l'aigu bien en tous les cas en parlant
de sa dette gagnent quand vous repensez
maintenant à cette époque c'est-à-dire à
los angeles quand vous étiez lacéré les
poignets avec une lame de rasoir
quand vous pensez à l'overdose que vous
avez fait au speed ball au sunset
marquis hôtel berline mais je me
rappelle pas tout ça mais enfin quand
vous pensez à ça aujourd'hui à cette
époque d'oka ça fait partie de mon
parcours de ma vie c'est ce que je peux
dire c'étaient des choix que j'avais
fait à l'époque on en fait trop
comme pour tout bon c'est vrai que vous
êtes mort pendant savez que vous êtes
noir pendant deux minutes quand vous
avez fait cette overdose
au sein de cette marque est
effectivement je crois que j'étais
on m'a emmené à l'hosto d'un jour à
l'autre
on m'a dit ça après coup effectivement
je ne le savais pas sur le moment mais
je vais prouver
c'est ce genre d'histoire un petit peu
rasoir mais à l'époque je me rendais
comme je faisais je me disais moi mais
c'est ce débile mais il a fallu que
j'arrive à ce stade là pour me rendre
compte de la bêtise à ce que je faisais
je me rendais compte que c'était débile
et jusque là je ferai que je m'amusais
mais c'était pas c'était pas très bon
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous pourriez dire
aux gens qui vous regardent aux gens qui
nous regardent que la drogue c'est sympa
et par qu'on en prend pour être bien et
puis qu au bout d'un mois deux mois
trois mois on en prend juste pour pas
être mal et que ça devient un enfer on
retrouve le même problème avec l'alcool
y'a pas de faire la différence la drogue
qu'on parlait des choses qui paraissent
acceptables au départ et puis qui
entraîne des problèmes par la suite
justement à cause des excès moi je me
suis battu publiquement contre la drogue
ce beau combat était publique et et j'ai
voulu effectivement l'aide du public
dans tout ce que je peux espérer c'est
que aujourd'hui moi même je puisse faire
quelque chose de positif
j'ai la chance de pouvoir être au cola à
faire de la musique
d'ailleurs c'est la raison pour laquelle
je me suis lancé là dedans au départ
j'ai la chance d'avoir eu une deuxième
chance je sais chance de m'en sortir je
crois qu'il faut pouvoir demander de
l'aide
quelle joie c'est la chose la plus
difficile quelqu'un qui deviendra assez
moi j'ai eu la chance d'abord autour de
moi des gens qui travaillaient pour voir
avec moi quelques vrais amis mon manager
de la funk et là aussi qui m'a aidé